[Musique]
évidemment ils ont bloqué encore la
route ça j'espère qu'ils ont nettoyé
eux-mêmes leur bordel au bout d'un
moment c'est bon quoi c'est pas possible
moi je comprends qu'il faut qu'il faille
prendre conscience de ce qui arrive et
il y a des problèmes mais pas faire ça à
faire chier tout le monde voir
Saint-Germain quand même alors
vous n'avez rien compris
bourgeois qui vous emporte alors que le
monde est en train de vaciller moi je
vais te dire ça va mal se terminer mais
bien sûr
à chaque fois je pense à eux je te le
dis que c'est un mal terminé parce que
ça va pas être le gars avec la
trottinette
parce que voilà regardez en plus c'est
intelligent le Père Noël on en parle ils
sont devant le ministères
le bonhomme vert
moi je trouve que c'est militants sont à
l'écologie ce que les gilets jaunes
étaient à l'économie voilà donc je vois
pas pourquoi est-ce que les gilets
jaunes faisaient venir ici on disait
bravo les gilets jaunes
mais
l'écologie c'est encore plus important
que l'économie parce que ça va de notre
de notre survie oui mais là ils font
chier ils le font mal
que les pauvres c'est qu'ils ont passé
la journée de merde est assis sur la
brique il y a ils ont à mon avis ils
sont passés encore une fois
des députés c'est bien pour ça qu'il
faut se battre à l'Assemblée mais pas
dans la rue à faire chez les enfants
à l'Assemblée nationale ils ont élu des
députés écologiques
Delphine mon ami Jérôme Rodriguez alors
il t'appelle la Miss France mais
Delphine non mais la Miss France
Delphine elle peut arrêter de comparer
les gilets jaunes on a bloqué personne
nous on ouvrait les péages pour que les
gens puissent circuler gratuitement et
c'est vrai c'est vrai voilà
je suis désolé on devait prendre des
itinéraires bises parce qu'il y avait
les gilets jaunes partout et je ne dis
pas que c'est pas bien parce que moi
j'étais pour ces gens-là qui qui sont
des lanceurs d'alerte et au moins quand
les Français ils étaient vraiment
mobilisés c'était bien Delphine sauf que
là on est au bal du ciment j'adore ce
mot je t'explique les Français là je
vais te dire les franchis des Français
là ils pensent qu'à une chose c'est un
pouvoir manger le 11 du mois donc quand
tu vas leur dire écoute-moi bien
échauffer la maison écologie pour
quelque chose de de de puéril l'écologie
bien sûr que c'est important mais je
vais te dire l'écologie le problème là
on est dans une urgence et l'écologie là
je vais te dire l'écologie
que les gens puissent manger le le 15 du
mois et pas leur dire on va et
d'ailleurs l'absurer la planète oui mais
c'est pas c'est pas 20 20
à Paris qui vont sauver la planète et
pourquoi ils expliquent et pourquoi ils
vont pas à la montagne là au
Grand-Bornand où ils font les épreuves
de bien je sais pas où là non mais il y
a plein de camions qui montent en
montagne pour mettre de la neige
artificielle pourquoi ils vont pas faire
bloquer là-bas c'est là-bas la pollution
puisque après ils vont se plaindre que
les gens
s'il te plaît donne-moi des idées il y a
des il y a des gars qui travaillent dans
les stations dans des restaurants des
mécaniques ou des trucs ça fait vivre
plein de gens qui qui sont comme là qui
sont déjà on peut parler avec toi ou je
ne suis pas le chauffeur de bus
chéri dis pas n'importe quoi tu vas
mettre plein de gens au chômage c'est
pas une mauvaise blague non plus parce
qu'il y a quatre abrutis qui vont
s'asseoir sur une piscine bah non il
faut pas leur donner des idées allez
faire les abrutis ou ça pollue mais
c'est facile de dire le Qatar ça pollue
ça ça pollue ça pollue et t'asseoir
boulevard Saint-Germain pour bloquer des
gens qui vont au boulot qui sont dans
des bus ça ne sert strictement à rien ça
c'est sûr donc si vous voulez bloquer
allez bloquer où les gens polluent allez
bloquer ou il y a des paquebots allez
bloquer dans les aéros
Jérôme qui me dit encore un truc merci
Jérôme parce que je trouve que tout ce
que tu dis est très intéressant
déjà tu arrives en retard le samedi
Delphine le samedi c'est vrai que il y a
peu de tu travailles le samedi il y a
pas d'émission il y a des mailles à des
boutiques qui travaillent moi j'ai
toujours énormément et les Français ont
la tête dans l'assiette aujourd'hui et
sauf que l'assiette elle est vide et
quand la tête tape il n'y a pas de
bifteck pour amortir c'est vrai que
voilà et c'est vrai que là aujourd'hui
sa priorité c'est pas de d'aller faire
leur mal là-bas
si on symbolique et je les soutiens pas
maintenant parce qu'en fait c'est
absurde et c'est complètement hypocrite
et c'est contre-productif et l'écologie
punitive on n'en veut pas hier on
parlait de quoi on parlait des coupures
d'électricité les gens ils sont paniqués
de ça ils sont pas ils sont paniqués de
ça vous allez voir vous allez voir vous
allez voir ce qui se passe et sur les
nucléaires en fait l'écologie voulait
les fermer mais aujourd'hui les gens ils
ont su mais ouvrez les centrales
nucléaires parce que grâce à ça on peut
avoir l'électricité
la France même si toute la France fait
un truc qu'on a on est vraiment on est
les champions de l'écologie on va dire
la France mais les champions
je peux te dire on va pas sauver la
planète
de Père Noël là ils sont fabriqués en
Chine donc ça pollue énormément pour
venir donc
il y a des gens il y a Clément qui me
dit ah bah ça ah mais c'est rien
on a rien contre eux ils font leur
action mais rien que ça va mal se
terminer
on a vu le mec l'autre fois qui nous a
sorti qui a dit il y en a un qui bouge
il y en a un qui bougent
les gilets jaunes je vous dis mais c'est
pas le même mouvement Delphine
un message il y a quelqu'un qui dit des
écologique qui me dit l'écologie pour
moi est un souci de riche les personnes
qui n'arrive pas à finir le moi qui
n'arrivent pas à nourrir leurs familles
elles en ont rien à [ __ ] de l'écologie
qu'est-ce que tu réponds à ça c'est le
souci de l'humanité c'est le souci de
l'humanité c'est pas un souci de riche
mais quand tu penses déjà à vivre euh
survivre et à survivre
dans un mois et à nourrir
ce sera plus ou que vous ayez de
l'argent on va tous mourir
Delphine
tu peux être le plus exemplaire que tu
veux en France voilà tu peux être le
pays le plus exemplaire au niveau des
sandwichs changera rien bah oui ce qui
fasse des actions
et tu crois que les gens en Chine et les
gens en Inde ils ont même en allemand de
symbole dépasse notre force économique
et symboles non dépasse la France avec
les symboles Sénégal demain
les mecs j'adore la France c'est un pays
exceptionnel bien sûr mais il faut
arrêter de croire que la France et voilà
et force de proposition et écouter dans
le monde entier la France c'est des gens
aiment bien alors je les explique pour
les Américains moi j'étais qu'une
Américaine la dernière fois
comment s'appelle le président
français
attention
américaine
[Applaudissements]
et alors son prénom juste le prénom
soyez gentil c'est Noël le prénom je me
rappelle même plus agréable docteur
Stanford pratique en France ou elle est
venue spécialement pour vous des
États-Unis spécialement pour moi des
États-Unis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]